اخبار الحرب على غزه بايجاز من مدينه بيت
لحم اهلا بكم وزاره الصحه بغزه تعلن
ارتفاع عدد ضحايا العدوان الاسرائيلي على
القطاع الى اكثر من 20 ال شهيد وقصف
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يستمر على مختلف
مناطق غزه والمفوض الاممي لشؤون اللاجئين
يقول ان وقف اطلاق النار هو السبيل الوحيد
لوقف ازهاق الارواح وايصال المساع
واطلاق الرهائن والجزيره ترصد معاناه
اهالي مخيم جباليا والنازحين شمالي القطاع
مع ازمه المياه الخانقه في ظل قصف
الاحتلال
والحصار جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يعلن
مقتل 14 ضابطا وجنديا خلال يوم واحد
ليرتفع عدد قتلاه الى
159 منذ بدء العمليه البريه كتائب القسام
تؤكد قتلها 12 جنديا في جحر الديك وخان
يونس وايقاع قتلى وجرحى في صفوف قوات
الاحتلال بين جبالي البلد والمعسكر هذا
ويقول نتنياهو في الجلسه الاسبوعيه
لحكومته ان الحرب تكبد اسرائيل اثمان
باهضه وفي الضفه الغربيه قوات الاحتلال
تقتحم مدنا وبلدات عده وتنفذ حملات دهم
واعتقالات واشتباكات عنيفه بين مقاومين
فلسطينيين وقوات الاحتلال في طول كرم
والجزيره ترصد تهجير الاحتلال لتجمعات
فلسطينيه في الاغوار تضم اكثر من ال000
شخص منذ السابع من
اكتوبر الجيش الامريكي يعلن اسقاط اربع
طائرات مسيره في البحر الاحمر ويقول انها
اطلقت من مناطق خاضعه للحوثيين في اليمن
هيئه التجاره البحريه البريطانيه تؤكد
تعرض سفينتين لحادث امنيين احدهما في باب
المندب والثاني غرب الحديه وتقول ان سفينه
ثالثه تعرضت لهجوم بمسيره قباله سواحل
الهند ومسؤول ايراني يؤكد للجزيره ان
طهران ابلغت واشنطن انها ليست اطفائي
حرائق ولا تصدر اوامر لحلفائها في
محور المق
الى
اللقاء